shanghai considered the heart of china's
financial sector rarely stops beating
yet the streets are eerily quiet 26
million residents are stuck at home
waiting for updates from the robot dogs
now being used to share public health
information
yeah it's a very strict lockdown in fact
i've seen people calling it
one of the strictest lockdowns in the
world we're not allowed to leave home at
all all public transport has been
cancelled
you're not even allowed to leave the
front
door china has frequently implemented
strict lockdowns to control the spread
of covet 19. there are currently 23
cities under full or partial lockdown as
china continues to strive to completely
eradicate the virus an all-encompassing
strategy known as covet zero one new
zealand gave up on last fall
epidemiologists now argue vaccines and
mask mandates are more effective
i don't think at this point
in fact at any point
long-term lockdown is really the answer
to you know to to responding to kobe 19.
chinese officials however say they are
unwavering in their goal a small army of
health officials was brought in to test
nearly all shanghai residents and while
over 20 000 asymptomatic cases were
caught
symptomatic cases numbered under 700.
people i don't think are worried in
china and in shanghai about the covet
itself and they're more worried i think
about catching it because of the hassle
that it will cause because of course in
china anyone who tests positive needs to
go into central quarantine the strain of
the lockdown is starting to show with
the rise in social media complaints
putting into question how long the
current strategy is sustainable
microlight global news toronto